[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Catherine
starts this hour off in Detroit hey
Katherine how are
you hi Dave and Ken thank you so much
for taking my call sure um I am seeking
advice today on my relationship okay um
I've been dating my boyfriend for almost
a year um and things have been going
really well but I have concerns that as
you know things continue to progress
hopefully down the path towards marriage
that our discrepancy in finances um
specifically income debt retirement
savings um will be a problem um and that
ultimately I might kind of find myself
in in a sugar mama type situation which
I'd really um you don't be that girl
yeah we already have a problem yeah I
love it good for you so uh how old are
you
I'm 38 and he is 35 okay cool and what
do you make I make 200 and he makes 45
okay all right and what does he
do um he works in construction and what
do you
do uh I work in the automotive industry
okay there's nothing wrong with anything
you've told me so far that uh makes us
incompatible as long as you're both in
agreement so what we found is there's
four things that um good research is
revealing that that if you agreed on
four things prior to marriage you have a
very high statistical probability of
staying married number one is money how
we handle it how we view it okay number
two because money fights and money
problems number one cause a divorce so
you got to deal with it so you're smart
to call a money show and talk about this
number two uh kids are we going to have
them how many how we going to treat them
are the inmates going to run the Asylum
that kind of stuff right number three
the crazy people in our family called
in-laws because everybody's got crazy in
their family and you don't think it's
you don't think you do it's
you so everybody's got it so how we
going to handle that how we going to
handle the extended crazy and and are we
going to stand beside each other in that
and number three is religion agreement
on religion and so if you're in
agreement on those four things you have
a very high probability let's go back to
the money one a minute you obviously are
a high income earner and he's obviously
a construction guy out there doing it
and but and yet you're falling in love
and that's cool all right uh that's not
my concern my concern would be his view
towards his debt how much debt has he
got and how does he view
it so he has um around about
50,000 um and um and when we started
dating I gave him the Total Money
Makeover um and he read it and I have
seen him change his spending Behavior
his you know started budgeting um really
trying to you know save and attack debt
so he bought into the idea that debt is
bad and he wants to get rid of
it yes and you think debt is bad and you
want to get rid of it so you're aligned
on that I'm yeah I'm completely debt
free baby step six I'm not talking about
where you are I'm talking about what you
believe you both believe Deb is bad and
you want to get rid of it aligned yes
okay then that that's the important
thing
so what are you worried about if he says
if he says oh baby it ain't no problem
I'm just going to work till Friday and I
don't I'm gonna buy I'm gonna get me a
new truck whenever I want to don't marry
him but he's not saying that I'm worried
about no he's not what
I'm worried is just or maybe need to
kind of come to to grips with is you
know I've worked really hard to be in
the financial situation I'm in because
i' I followed you all for um you know
most of my adult life and now we're
talking about you know what this would
entail would be ultimately taking on
someone else's debt because I don't see
any ways getting out of it you know in
the next few years no you're GNA marry
him and he's gonna have debt you're
gonna pay it off well wait a second why
why wait a second wait wait wait what's
wrong with that I I have a quick
question what what makes you think that
it's going to take him two years or so
to get I mean $50,000 if he gets serious
and he is in alignment he can get rid of
this debt you don't have to necessarily
marry all of it I I think if he's
aligned what I'd want to know is is how
gazelle intense is he willing to get and
stay that way and stay that way so that
you don't marry much if any first of all
we he hadn't even put a ring on it list
if if he had $200,000 worth of debt and
he's plowing through it and you marry
into it I'm okay yeah as long as yall
are aligned on getting rid of it that's
the thing you got to be what's what will
kill you is not being aligned not having
unless you just get all twisted up and
bothered inside your head and go like I
did him a favor and he owes me the rest
of his life now that's on you but but if
you're willing to just throw in and say
all right it's all in everything's in
the middle and we're all going to get
rid we're going to use my assets your my
debt your debt it's all hours now we're
going to clean it up and we're going to
live for the rest of our lives the way
you've been living so far
then you've got a good marriage
match I think that sounds good I think
that's a good plan yeah but if you if
you're having to drag his butt
along because he's going to misbehave
and he's going to you know everybody has
a car payment crap who needs that
garbage you know you don't you don't
want be that that is then you're you're
signing up for a problem yeah my concern
and again I'm not saying this is this
guy but there's a difference between
somebody believing something and doing
something yeah I'd like to see him he's
starting to take action on his new
beliefs and as long as he does that and
he's really you know he's taking two
extra jobs and he's attacking this debt
and this may be a great may be a great
find he's a great guy he just needed
some you know he just needed somebody
showing him the path right I think it's
a great test too not that she says it
that way and she doesn't position it
that way but if you if you're willing to
say yes to this guy I think you being
willing to say yes if he proposes is
based on you laying down the tough
conversation now while we're dating see
what we don't want to do is have the
tough difficult money conversations
after we've gotten engaged or after
we've gotten married I think at this
point what you've laid out seems like
he's a good guy and he seems like
there's alignment but now Dave is when I
think we have the difficult conversation
and she goes this is how I want to live
and I'm going to marry a guy who
believes in living this way and what you
want to married into is a shared Vision
not not a messed up past correct that's
right everybody's got a messed up past
that's right marrying into a shared
vision of where we're going and so I I
don't mind if you marry somebody who was
an alcoholic for 10 years but they've
been dry for 3 years age and they've
changed their life I don't count the I
don't count the previous against them y
I count where we're going is way more
important than where we've been Y and so
you know where we're going where are we
going and are we going to go together
and is it going to we're going to be an
agreement if I have to fight you all the
time about borrowing money and about
saving money I'm not going to be on
that's not that's not that's not an
alignment but if we're on if we're align
on that and I just got a head start on
you oh that's okay that's okay this is
the Ramsey Show create your free every
budget today the simplest way to budget
for your life